al momento de actualizar la información
económica en france 24 y es por eso que
nos acompaña por supuesto como siempre
nuestra compañera daniela hablándome
danny vamos a comenzar hablando de los
beneficiados no por esta tercera dosis
de vacuna que se está aplicando contra
el virus del cobi 19 ante la variante
delta las farmacéuticas son las grandes
triunfadoras claro que si santiago pues
hay gobiernos como los de chile alemania
e israel ahora también uruguay que ya
ofrecen una tercera dosis a sus
ciudadanos según expertos consultados
por la agencia reuters se espera que las
grandes beneficiadas sean por supuesto
las farmacéuticas estos mismos expertos
creen que este mercado podría rivalizar
con los seis mil millones de dólares en
ventas anuales de vacunas contra la
influenza solo facer variante y moderna
han previsto que sus ventas de
inyecciones entre 2021 y 2022 superarán
los 60 mil millones de dólares una parte
del análisis comprende también los
precios para ser cobro inicialmente 19 6
dólares por dosis de su vacuna en eeuu y
19,5 euros
europea sin embargo los precios han
subido alrededor de un 25% en entregas
posteriores santiago hay una crisis para
un sector de los trabajadores en chile-
trabajadores de codelco diana huelga
claro los precios del metal rojo han
tocado máximos históricos varias veces
desde que inició la pandemia y eso ha
generado santiago tensión en chile que
es el mayor productor del mundo la
semana pasada iniciaron huelga a algunos
mineros y todo apunta a que se van a
sumar más nuestra corresponsable en
santiago patricia luna nos tiene más
detalles
un tercer sindicato de la minera andina
acudiría en las próximas horas a huelva
sumándose a los otros dos sindicatos que
ya están en huelga desde el jueves
pasado y que amenazan con suspender
porque mantienen bajos mínimos la
producción de esta minera situada en la
cordillera de los andes y cercana a
santiago que produjo en 2020 184 mil
toneladas de este preciado metal esta
minera pertenece a la empresa estatal
codelco los trabajadores argumentan que
la directiva quiere quitarles su derecho
tradicional a la salud y que no ofrece
mejoras sociales en un momento en que el
precio del cobre alcanza cifras
históricas esta huelga se produce
también pocos días después de que la
minera escondida situada en antofagasta
en el norte del país alcanzar un acuerdo
'in extremis' con sus trabajadores por
otro tema siempre polémico el tema de
los bonos que para los trabajadores
mineros alcanzan cifras astronómicas
superiores a los 20 mil dólares y muy
por encima de la media chilena lo que
siempre reaviva el debate de si son
justos o no lo que es cierto es que
también estos trabajadores
arriesgan sus vidas cada vez que van a
trabajar a la mina recordemos que chile
es el mayor productor de cobre del mundo
y que este cobre también forma una parte
importante de sus exportaciones
danny hablamos ahora de la crisis
financiera en el barça ahora santiago el
presidente del club desnudo las finanzas
con corte a diciembre de 2020 que no
pintan nada bien y de lo cual culpó a la
administración anterior dijo que han
pasado dos años de aumentos salariales y
transferencias de jugadores bastante
costosas que entre otros le impidieron
darse el lujo de renovar el contrato con
lionel messi el club tiene una deuda de
mil 350 millones de euros y un
patrimonio negativo de 452 millones
además sus pérdidas estimadas para esta
vigencia son de
481 millones escuchemos
aquí todos nos apretamos
el cinturón todos estamos por la labor y
yo pondría que ahora hemos cogido aire
para un año y medio pero yo he hecho que
en un par de años está la
a la economía del club
como siempre con la cifra del día cuales
64 creció en julio la producción
industrial en china esto fue 19 puntos
menos que la de junio datos
decepcionantes que hicieron caer las
bolsas santiago gracias daniel hasta
aquí la información económica sigan
informando se enfrenta y 4 y en
transmití cuatro.com